[Music]  Taylor Swift and Joe Alwyn step out for  a day date in London the delicate singer  took a break from her reputation stadium  tour to spend some time with her British  beau the two looked happy and relaxed  leaving a pub in North London on  Wednesday after they reportedly shared a  meal of traditional fish and chips along  with two pints of London pride beer  [Music]  Taylor wore a striped tank top and  rust-colored skirt with her hair down  and straight while the 27 year old actor  kept his look casual in a white t-shirt  and jeans for the outing  though the pair have kept a low profile  since they began dating more than a year  ago they sure seem to be going strong  [Music]  [Applause]